hey what's up guys welcome back to our
channel this is officially the samuel
and amanda show i'm samuel and i'm
amanda and this is actually you know
what people so many people have said
that we should just call it the samanda
show i'm thinking as cringy as it is um
maybe not officially but maybe if we can
just say it is really cringy right now
should we call is this the samantha show
or the samurai show hey listen this week
we're going to be answering your
questions that you've got uh for me and
amanda amanda do you realize i've got
some really interesting news for you um
before i tell you that before i tell you
that this is what we're gonna be talking
about today number one financial freedom
challenges more financial freedom
challenges coming up maybe amanda's
gonna be involved maybe you're gonna be
involved we need your opinion uh number
two relationship advice
from amanda we've got a whole bunch of
questions if you've got questions for us
comment below but what i wanted to say
on right now to you
news for you what's this big news is
over the last week we've posted seven
videos the top two most popular videos
have both had you in them no way
oh my gosh let me guess which ah
obviously the podcast where you've
already been in two well yeah the
podcast and the car the tesla car ah the
mercedes the mercedes electric car by
the way i am a little bit dyslexic and i
sometimes get muddled up with my words
and stuff and people end up really
getting angry and hating on me like i
remember i think when we did the [ __ ]
calling it tesla it's a mercedes
with my car my range rover i said um
that it was uh petrol and it's diesel
but i'm like guys i don't i know all
cars that have petrol or diesel just
people are getting all like people like
you liar it's diesel i'm like not that
dude
um but anyhow how'd you wait man my
week's been good i've been really
enjoying my car if you haven't watched
that video then you need to watch the
video oh i'm so in love and i had my
first long journey in it and i had to
stop and charge and i was a bit like oh
but it was actually really really easy
and the superchargers charged the car
really really quick so yeah i'm loving
it i don't think i'm ever gonna go back
to um a petrol or diesel car
petrol
um yeah do you think because you were
quite worried about getting the car you
were like oh i love my discovery sport
and you're really worried about getting
it is it does it definitely been a good
move definitely a good move and it's so
quiet do you know what i drove your car
yesterday i drove samuel's range over my
deep my diesel his diesel range rover
and honestly babe it felt so heavy and
just so sluggish like when you try and
accelerate no don't say that compared to
my car my car before samuel's car used
to feel like i was floating my car
floats but now honestly babe drive my
car go into your car the difference i
was just like i am not jealous of your
car anymore how to drive anyway the
drive how about how i haven't got
anything on mine go on
but yeah the week's been good it's been
really busy as well we've had lots of
people over filming winners wednesdays
which has been really really cool i
always love it meeting everyone and
yesterday we met ashley and ellen who i
actually met when they came to the crash
course for the first time ever and it's
just unbelievable how much they've done
in such a short space of time so i
always love seeing everyone's journey
and then when they come to our house
it's like oh my gosh here you are you've
done so well sir ashley and ellen um
they actually came down in december to
the crash course and it was when the
lockdown just lifted just before
christmas but then
the day before the crash course
the lockdown came back in yeah and they
landed in the uk and then we were like
literally we've had to cancel these
crash courses
i felt so bad i said look if anyone's
traveled far come and meet me in person
come on we did the crash course at the
um studio we did a virtual crash course
but if you've traveled overseas or
anything come on down we have people
from like hong kong australia abu dhabi
well ashley and ellen came from abu
dhabi met them in person it was really
fun and now just within eight months
they've become financially free and they
they never went back to aberdabe after
the crash because after the crash course
they were like
we're gonna cancel our ticket home we're
staying here and they basically did a
financial freedom challenge with no
money and now they're making five
thousand pounds a month so you've
obviously you get you get to see all
this yeah i love i love seeing it and
you know what they say it all starts at
the crash course and it's yeah for them
so it does it does um
so uh to the edge i mean yesterday as
well we had three i did eight eight
interviews yesterday with with people uh
three of them were winners on a
wednesdays um and most mostly were
filmed so you'll be seeing stuff coming
out on youtube but the house was just
full wasn't it yeah how do you cope
question how do you cope as a wife
um and a homemaker you know you're
looking after the kids
having like groups of people constantly
coming in the house and whatever i don't
know it's it's quite nice because it's
people that we obviously know like and
trust so it's really cool i just i quite
like it it's just fun for me it's just
kind of like making cups of teas making
them feel at home making them feel
relaxed before the interview because
sometimes people are a bit nervous but i
just kind of calm them a bit i hope
anyway
you definitely can't meet anyway you
have a calming presence you have a
calming progress thank you all right so
questions that we've got and then we're
going to talk about the financial
freedom challenges coming up also we've
got lorton evans and david i went i
moved into the house i'm going to be
helping one of those people become a
property millionaire and you're going to
be helping choose who it's going to be
[Music]
we'll talk about that later
but we've got a whole bunch of questions
um it's been a great day so far by the
way we usually film these podcasts we
usually film these youtube videos
together literally a couple hours before
it goes out so today is saturday yeah um
because we want to keep up to date
relevant um today's been a fun day we're
refinancing some houses yeah um which is
which is really fun all right let's have
a look at questions so all right here's
a question
someone said
please do a video on what path to take
straight after education
i aspire to be exactly like you and
amanda
that's sweet but i don't know how one
person can aspire to be like me and
amanda because we're very different
people
this is princess a by the way
as a first gen immigrant it is truly
inspiring to see her thriving in
property
thank you would you describe yourself as
an immigrant there
yeah yeah yeah an immigrant well i moved
from zimbabwe didn't i so i am i'm a
first generation immigrant i think i
don't i think so anyway i have no clue
where to go or what to do after school
so come on give us some immigrant advice
is that what i said no no that was my
bit at the end i mean
i was like okay some immigrant advice
i think it just depends what you want to
do
so if you want to do a job
if you want to be in a career where you
have to go to university like being a
doctor or a lawyer or dentist or
whatever then obviously take those steps
to do that but if you want to be a
property then i'd suggest starting off
at the property investors crash course
we've had people like lots of different
ages come young teenagers have been even
like we've even had like immigrants come
yeah doesn't matter people from all
walks of life coming so i think it just
depends what you want to do but if
you're interested in property then
definitely definitely definitely i
highly recommend coming to the crash
course yeah and also as well you want to
hang around people that you want to
become like so if you want to become a
doctor
i mean i probably suggest finding some
friends who are doctors and looking at
their lives look at how much they're
getting paid look at their uh whether
they're happy and then decide do you
really want to do that and then if you
do perhaps start being hanging around
people that are also training to be
doctors that also aspiring to be doctors
but they're also doctors if you want to
be a builder you know i wanted to be a
builder when i was like a teenager so i
went and worked on a building site
for six weeks
and got all the experience that was when
i realized that these hands
weren't meant to be oh my gosh i can't
even imagine really
not your bag it's just not but no but i
i'm not physically no but
i
i worked on a building site for six
weeks
it's
i think amanda thinks that because now i
delegate everything like that so i don't
do anything now i just use my brain and
my voice and not my hands
um because
it's less timing so you can't imagine it
now no i can't imagine enough but yeah
um but yeah so good luck princess aye i
hope it goes well and if you need help
just give us a shout or hit us on
instagram yeah
okay
sander
typesteen says
i have completely the same taste as you
two have hello good taste he's talking
about in property though okay
because this is the response to our last
week's video where we were like looking
at mansions
especially the palm trees samuel i love
it i do love i'm a sucker for palm trees
palm trees and white houses just make me
feel like i'm on holiday
i always say i wanted to be cash it
compacts it feels homely have you two
ever thought about leaving the uk for a
country with better climate
we actually have halfway yeah we have we
don't remember i mean it wasn't like
serious serious we never like took steps
to do it but barcelona we love barcelona
we didn't love that we didn't want to
move there for good not for good but we
just thought we could run for a few
months and just for fun yeah i used to
want to live in america when i was
growing up i was like oh my gosh i am
destined to be in america and then after
being to america
it's just not anywhere i just would
never want to live
no
i thought you loved america i love
america but i don't want to live there i
don't want to raise my kids there why
i i don't love for example that they um
have the guns like that's just a thing
that you're allowed to own a gun i don't
like that why do you not like that
because i think it's dangerous and i
think you just end up getting really bad
accidents so what they argue is the guns
the reason people are allowed guns is to
protect themselves against the state
should the state turn into like a
communist state or something wow is the
composition going yeah but i mean come
on what are the chances of that
happening what what
look through history and it happens
again and again and again and again okay
but what so what are you just gonna all
line up with all your guns no
no no no no no
and i'm not saying i'm four guns i'm
really not yeah i'm just saying that in
history sometimes the government the
government are the biggest of the
biggest fear of the biggest enemy people
yeah right
the government can just go actually you
know what
we're gonna say you can't do this you
can't work you can't and and when the
people have guns it just means that they
have a level of the people could very
easily rebel against the government so
the government had to stay in line and
not be complete jerks okay so that's the
rationale behind allowing people to have
glass yeah
well money's not buying good thing i
don't live there then because i don't
agree with it i don't think the thing is
obviously yeah people do end up then
yeah people and things basically i'm not
i i like to go there for holiday but i
don't want to live there so would you
ever want to live anywhere abroad um i
think we're quite open sorry
i think we're quite open i mean we say
we never say never but go on i mean oh
i'm just gonna say that i am
in love with england yeah i love england
i love the climate different climates
and also you might think oh i want to be
somewhere really hot to live but it's
like really really
the same people that say that often moan
in english summers so annoying they're
like oh it's so hot don't be that person
i know so but the thing is
lying on a beach or sitting outside a
pool when it's 30 degrees is amazing but
actually
when it's 30 degrees
and you got a job to do and you got to
work yeah it's actually not that amazing
i like the fact that we have an english
summer where it's hot then we have the
spring which is just beautiful and it
filled with hope and then we have the
autumn which is beautiful and and orange
and and and you know when the the
beautiful sunset and the leaves fall and
then we have the winter which is a bit
long but we then go on holiday yeah we
go somewhere beautiful so it's i like
the seasons i like england i love the
culture the people the opportunities
would i ever move i don't think so maybe
to zimbabwe
would you ever move to zimbabwe i think
and maybe not permanently but split our
time zumba is a great yeah i think it's
a great country a great country let us
know what you think though in the
comments if you have more questions for
me or amanda drop them in the questions
okay so we've got caribbean curls
says
do you get stressed out dealing with
property and all the updates and changes
hmm
oh
i would say about that there are a lot
of updates and changes but when you are
in a community filled with property
investors you know about them pretty
quick it's not like also we've got
letting agents that keep us posted of
any tenant changes or tenant rights or
anything we need to know about that um
we are obviously we're property
investors so i'm really ahead of the
news so anything that's coming or
changing we're aware of it um there are
changes you do need to keep your finger
on the pulse normally when there's a
change it's normally an opportunity as
well so
i wouldn't say i get stressed about it
no um i don't know how you feel because
you deal with a lot of our property
stuff yeah like you said i mean there's
always updates from the agents and stuff
so you do you when you just in the know
with everyone you usually do find out
about these things but no the only thing
i find annoying about property is um all
the paperwork and just administrations
that's the only thing that i'm like oh
like when you're refinancing a house
like all that side of stuff i'm just
like oh come on sometimes people like
what about this where we find some
houses at the moment this morning very
much it's saturday man mandy gets yeah
tell them what happened randomly get a
call this morning and then she's just
like what's the address you were
financing what's your dress like what
were you addressing a few she was so
vague and yet so like demanding of she's
like can you tell me the dress at the
property
we're actually financing seven houses
right now which probably are you talking
about where you need to go through
security and then she goes as well mandy
answered the phone she goes can i speak
to um mr leeds and mandy's like um my
husband's a bit busy
well i can speak to you because you're
also on the on the top of these it's
like
why asked to speak to me in the first
place yeah it's just crazy and she rang
my phone as well but she was asking for
you and then she as if you wouldn't have
a clue because you're a woman you
wouldn't know actually i don't know
mandy knows everything so yeah so yeah
so that's the only stuff that i find a
bit annoying i also think that when
you're in the environment
all of our friends are in property our
family are in property it's just like
standard normal so if there's a change
or an issue everyone's in it together
it's not like you're just on your own oh
what's happening everyone's here
together so i think it's great all right
last question and then
we're going to talk about the financial
freedom challenges okay so stay tuned
stay tuned stay tuned if you enjoy the
video hit like don't forget as well
you've got questions for me or amanda
hit them below hit them below okay
don king says
a question of you guys you seem to have
a good relationship going on what are
your tips i would like both
sides amanda and yours
also so many relationships and marriages
have broken down across the board even
high profiles during covid how have you
and amanda managed to keep your going
via covet respect um
do you want to answer that first you can
go first oh
okay i would i would just say look
firstly choose the right partner in the
first place if you choose a partner that
you're not quite compatible with and you
don't actually like each other that much
then you might be able to get along just
fine when you're both working and you're
really busy but then as soon as you have
to be you have to be together that's
when you realize man we don't like each
other and i think one of the things that
when lockdown happened i think couples
sometimes were forced to be together and
they realized actually i don't like you
that much it's the same as when your
kids grow up and move out and then
you're like actually we don't really get
on that well you don't realize because
you're not so i think you know choo choo
find someone that you are compatible
with in the first place and then
secondly um just put each other first
and have fun and don't take don't take
yourself too seriously um if me and
amanda ever have like a slight
disagreement or a little thing a little
niggle that could end up becoming an
argument we just laugh it off we don't
you don't try and win the argument you
got to win the marriage
um you can win the argument or be right
but then
you're on the same team you're just
going to be with them afterwards anyway
it's not like you're
it's some meeting outside of the house
boom you're in the argument and then you
go home and ah let me tell you what
happened no you're in the oven and
you're together afterwards still like so
just you know put the other person first
have fun don't take yourself too
seriously um
be
live in the moment
that's it really and choose the right
partner
i think that's really important and i
also just think communicating so saying
how you feel when you feel it maybe not
in the moment but saying how you feel so
because sometimes you can bottle things
up so much and then you end up resenting
the person then it then ex you explode
at a time when it's just like a little
things happen
so i think that you should always be
sort of in good communication with each
other i think that's a really really big
thing in addition to what you said
another thing is as well if your partner
does something that you don't like or
you find annoying or if they upset you
or whatever normally the natural
tendency is to like flare up or to say
oh what is that and that causes an
argument what we do is if i do something
or amanda or something which the other
person doesn't like or thinks oh that's
a bit out of order is we don't say
anything there and then
we'll
wait
and then five minutes later or five
hours later or at the appropriate time
we call it the cold light of day and
then you bring it up in a really
reasonable way rather than trying to get
into an argument or like mandy sometimes
does it it's really serious mandy will
sometimes write me a letter
write it down and just like hey you were
a jerk you did this this this i'm just
baffled help me out help me understand
what were you thinking and then i'll
read it and it's like oh damn i need to
think through what i'm going to say and
how yeah that's only happened maybe two
times or three times but but but that
could very easily be an argument so um
but i think the biggest thing is
relationship advice wise is to not take
anything too seriously and just have fun
and that's true and also lastly just to
again be with someone that's right for
you but also when you are with someone
don't try to change them no one's
perfect so if you're with someone just
sort of accept them for who they are
because
they say it as well that
most
um relationships end because the man
doesn't want the woman to ever change
and she does
or the woman wants the man to change
but he doesn't okay
so powerful because like a lot of men
are like i want you to be exactly sure
but the thing is women change
go through different seasons have kids
want to be career focused for a few
years they want to be family focused
yeah changes in their life you know like
you might want to go and write a book
might want something and i think as a
husband
i want amanda to just be really happy
and to go through i'm not like wanting
amanda to be like in a certain way for
me but then at the same time uh if
amanda wanted me to change
i haven't changed since since we started
dating i'm exactly literally just the
same you're very consistent and i love
that if manny's waiting for me
well one day he'll be rich enough that
he'll just
be
at home more with the kids guess what
i'll never be rich enough it would never
ever ever happen
um
yeah you know actually someone said to
me a close family member said to me um
samuel when will enough be enough and
it's like never
it's not like i'm doing this because i'm
trying to get to a certain status i'm
trying to earn a certain amount of money
i'm doing this because i love the game
and actually
true happiness comes from progression
if you're not progressing you can't be
happy so if enough was enough and i was
like oh i'm done now guess what i'd
probably get depressed so enough will
never be enough
and mandy gets that and i get manly so
understanding communication love care
respect respects another one i'll never
disrespect amanda in front of people i
only do that behind closed doors i'll
kiss her out i'll cut her out i'll cuss
her out when the doors now i'm just
kidding
but yeah talk each other down worst
thing ever right don't do that oh it's
just what would be an example of that
i don't know like if you see all the
time if your partner says something like
i did this and then the woman then
belittles him or says oh no you didn't
no well i don't know it's just oh it's
just i don't know i hate it when people
do that in front of me i'm just like oh
yeah i've seen this where couples kind
of like try and knock each other down
yeah oh it wasn't that big i wasn't and
they'll try and down but undo someone's
you know
ah yeah that's terrible you don't want
it you don't want it you don't want to
do that in private or be or or behind
closed doors but in public or behind or
in private but definitely not in public
um all right so financial freedom
challenges how do you cope how do you
cope with me going off for like when i
first did my financial freedom chance i
literally just said i'm not coming back
until i'm financially free starting from
scratch new identity no access to my
bank i can talk to you over the phone
but ain't gonna see you i'm gonna be
away until i become financially free it
could be three months six months
hopefully i'll see you at christmas yeah
oh my goodness you're crying like a baby
i was crying because i didn't know how
long he was gonna be away and it was the
first time he'd ever done that i didn't
i didn't know it was just like the
unknown and i was literally just
thinking i'm not gonna see him paradise
and just really like upset when you left
i left my big four-headed baby that was
that was so mean i know so ruby our
first ruby at first baby
when she was born she had a little bit
of a big forehead and
people in the comments cussing her out i
know
don't be mean to videos yeah yeah oh my
gosh so yeah so that was like oh my
goodness but then obviously you finished
that within a week you were back home
and it was like oh okay so then when you
were doing them after that i just kind
of knew like oh yeah i know the crack
he's gonna be gone for a week i'm gonna
be gonna gonna be gone for a week gonna
come back bye
so i knew what to expect but do you
think though that that is almost like i
feel like my audience like that a little
bit now as well though they're just like
oh sam's in the financial freedom chase
oh we know he's gonna do it but he's
like i don't know that when i got one
i'm scared yeah for you i guess pressure
it's a lot of pressure and the fact that
samuel doesn't do any preparation
beforehand because i'm a planner so i
like to know like right i'm gonna do
this this this and that like for you
it's literally just like okay blank
split and then everything's happening on
camera so as you see it is how it's
happening so i just could never do that
i think it's a lot of pressure to just
kind of put yourself out there have it
filmed and then put out it's just like
oh
would you do a financial freedom
challenge with me that's what i want to
know would you do a financial freedom
challenge with me if i was like look i'm
going to come to your house we're going
to spend a week together working on your
property business would you do it i've
done it a lot of people i'm going to be
doing more up and coming because i think
that it's
it's magical it's magical because when
you put a timeline on yourself and put
pressure on yourself it's amazing what
you can achieve in a short space of time
you know it's like if you say i'm gonna
spend two years doing this guess what it
will take you two years if you say now
i'm gonna do this in seven days you can
get so much done when you just focus
focus focus evans lawton david one of
them i'm gonna be doing the millionaire
challenge with oh my goodness
helping them training them become a
property millionaire over two to three
years that's gonna be awesome um we've
got david and evans and lawton in the
run-up for that who who do you think who
do you think deserves it oh my gosh they
all did amazingly well i think it's such
a tough decision that you have to make
i'm going to be making the decision next
week
next week or the week after the next
sort of ten days i don't know i don't
know all i know is that i'm rooting for
all of them because i think
whoever you pick they deserve it okay
25th of august
that is when i've got to make my
decision 25th of august who do you think
david david echols lauren hotwood or
evans willie comment below put it in
your diary the 25th because it's going
to be i'm going to be live streaming it
as a premier video on youtube on the
25th
put that in your diary uh mandy final
words of wisdom hit it to the people oh
my goodness okay i would say invest in
yourself and take action those three
people that samuel just talked about
lawton evans and david they all immerse
themselves did the ff challenge with you
yeah and i mean in that time they've
invested you know you invested in them
they've gone on the training and now
they're doing all amazingly well
i just think that it's so so important
whether it's in i guess like getting
educated in property or whether it's
just your well-being your mental health
just just invest in yourself because
you're the most important person and
everything begins with you that's so
true you are your best asset you know
you invent you'll buy a house oh i'm
gonna buy a house because you might go
up in value one day what about yourself
you've got to back that pony now back
yourself uh if you're gonna don't gamble
money or don't do the lottery if you're
gonna bet you should bet on yourself
invest in yourself i would agree with
that high five partner
awesome awesome awesome hey i hope you
enjoyed the podcast whether you're
listening to this or whether you're
watching this on youtube we love you we
appreciate you let us know your
questions for us in the comments no
matter how personal or random they might
be put them in the comment box and we
will see you next time see you guys
thanks for watching
[Music]